nikki is in Boone North Carolina hi
Nikki welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi
thank you for taking my call
sure what's up hi so my husband I
recently completed baby steps like 3b
where we saved 20% down for our house
excellent thank you and we set aside
some money for our baby's birth but I
ended up having some complications and
was in the hospital for five days and it
dipped into our emergency fund so now
we're trying to decide if you should
keep our emergency fund intact
and only do 15% on the house or do the
full 20 and just gazelle or emergency if
I'd back up to where it should be so how
much is in your emergency fund now about
a month and a half how much money is in
your emergency fund now about $3,500
$3,500 yes and how much do you have
saved for your home is it under contract
yes
and what is your household income um
fifty-six five hundred okay and so
you're about three thousand short on
your emergency fund right yes that is
correct
okay how quick can you rebuild it if you
close on the house with 20 down we think
we can do it in about eight months
that's a little slow you get to get to
about $9,000 okay yeah but I mean yeah
okay so you're gonna add six thousand
dollars in nine months yeah okay yeah I
put 20% down
thank you listen when you move in the
house you can't buy anything for the
house yeah they're not one thing you
can't have a new spatula for the kitchen
that was our plan not why not 20 cents
not a pair of curtains
you hang sheets over the window okay you
cannot spend any money until you get
this emergency fund rebuilt you follow
me yes you're going to turn that nine
months into a nine years if you start
furnishing this house
very true be careful because normal
people will screw this up and I'm
counting on you being weird not normal
well thanks to your program we were very
weird and we really appreciate all you
taught us ok write that warning down
because otherwise my advice is probably
bad advice but thanks for the call we
appreciate you joining us hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show and so
you have to break the cycle you have to
flip this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind